on june 3rd 1978
at age 13 a young girl named amelia won
her first major national writing contest
prior to this amelia had already begun
establishing herself as a young writing
prodigy
within her local and neighboring
communities she had won several other
smaller local writing contests
and her work was already touching on
heavy concepts dark emotions
and wisdoms well beyond her years
naturally
art in this case writing as it tends to
often be
was a way for amelia to deal with her
beginning mental struggles around this
time
to take her early depressed soak
thoughts and lay them out to dry
on the page
following the award ceremony of the
event emilia would find herself being
interviewed
for the very first time the interview
was for a community access television
show
about local arts and culture while being
asked a handful of the obvious cliche
questions the interviewer asked amelia
so what do you think the secret to your
success is
to being such a good writer at such a
young age amelia quickly tried to think
of the most professional and impressive
sounding answer
then she said i think the secret is
passion
you really have to love what you're
doing to do it well and i love writing
i'm always thinking about it and looking
for that feeling it gives me
[Music]
on november 14 1981 at age 16
emilia would find herself on her first
network television show
appearing in a documentary short series
about up-and-coming artists from around
the world
her segment was primarily an interview
intercut with b-roll
covering her background her inspirations
the extremely dark bleak nature of her
work
her struggles with depression and so
forth at some point
the interviewer asked what would you say
to other young aspiring artists and
writers looking to follow in your
footsteps
and your mind what do you think the
secret is to making good art
amelia quickly thought to herself then
she said
i mean i think it's sort of different
for everyone of course
but generally i think the secret for me
is honesty
not just honesty with others but more
importantly yourself
it's confronting your own weaknesses
your fears your psychosis
your confusions the things that make you
beautiful just as much as the things
that make you vile and horrible
on september 28 1983 at 18 years old
after being noticed by an executive
editor for a top-tier literary magazine
emilia was contacted and featured as
part of their emerging writers issue
an entire multi-page article was written
about her as it chronicled
her recent travels her work her personal
views on writing
and so forth the general tone of the
article was how well
amelia's work seemed to hit and mirror
the alienated nihilistic sensibilities
of the modern person
how each new piece she put out be it a
poem essay
short story or book was seemingly
pushing the limits of acceptable themes
and ideas
delving into exceptionally difficult
areas of the human psyche
and rendering disturbing and sad parts
of life into something somehow beautiful
and worthwhile the last full spread of
the article was an interview
between emilia and an editor of the
magazine one of the questions in
particular read
a lot of artists and writers have
different routines or sources of
inspiration
to get them in the right mindset to work
do you have any practices or songs
or anything that helps you are there any
tricks or secrets to making the work you
do
amelia's answer read no not really i
just like to be sad when i work
i pretty much need to be but that's
pretty easy considering i'm almost
always sad
the follow-up question read what's your
take on the concept of the tortured
artist
would you say things like sadness pain
and suffering are important for a writer
or
artist yes amelia's one word answer read
essential the next follow-up question
read no
not essential it's not like it's
depression or angst itself that makes
art good
but i think in my opinion the greatest
work is always just what strives for
truth
and insofar as i can tell the truth is
pretty sad and painful
so i'd say those two eventually meet in
some way or another
on june 12 1989 after her third official
novel released to almost immediate
massive worldwide acclaim as part of her
press tour
amelia found herself on her first late
night talk show
appearing as a guest on one of the most
popular major network talk shows of the
time
during the interview after the host did
his little comedic banter back and forth
near the end he asked amelia in the sort
of hacky talk show way
it seems like most people want to be a
famous artist or writer at some point in
their life
but of course just about no one ever
actually becomes one
if you could go back in time and tell
someone like yourself what have you
learned throughout this process
what's the secret amelia laughed a
little and then responded
i don't know i sort of hate to play into
this type of stuff but i don't know i
i think it's at least some degree of
dysfunctionality you have to be
dysfunctional to do this kind of stuff
to just sit in a room alone all the time
and stare at a blank page and think yeah
i have something important to say here
to live that way
in this kind of chaotic unpredictable
lifestyle it requires a certain kind of
discontent or dysfunction i'm not a
particularly happy person if you haven't
noticed in my work
the crowd laughed a little but it's not
that i've become unhappy because of my
work
my work is a symptom not the source or
maybe even better
a treatment and so in truth i credit a
lot of my work to my depression and
insomnia
i often find myself staying up all night
just thinking about how miserable things
are
and then hopefully by morning there's
something on the page and it seems to
work enough for me to make a living out
of the whole thing
so yeah personally i i do think the
secret is probably some
heightened degree of torment or
dysfunction or whatever else you want to
call it
have you ever just tried therapy the
host responded with a sort of joking
underhanded tone
the audience laughed again yes actually
i have
amelia responded and how did it go the
host replied
well pretty much right up front i asked
the therapist if the process might
affect my creativity
and she said i have to be honest it
could so i shook her hand
said thank you and never went back so
you like being dysfunctional
the host went on with i don't know if i
like it amelia responded
but i don't know if i want to fix myself
if i'm working well
over the following years amelia's career
would continue to elevate
she would become known by just about
anyone who knew anyone in the world of
art and mainstream
culture a feat very few writers ever
have or will achieve
throughout this time though amelia would
find herself frequently dipping more and
more into the depths of her depression
but as her depression seemed to increase
her work seemed to only get better
and better not wanting to retry therapy
or go on any mind-altering medications
that might affect her creativity and
work
but eventually coming to terms with the
fact that she needed to do something to
become at least somewhat more bearable
she hired a leading health coach to help
her eat and live a slightly healthier
life
during her first appointment the health
coach asked amelia some general
questions about her diet
amelia told her what she generally ate
on an average day
she said she normally had things like
cereal with milk smoothies or eggs with
cheese for breakfast
things like ham and cheese sandwiches
french onion soup or salads with blue
cheese dressing for lunch
stuff like lasagna mac and cheese
burrito bowls
quesadillas turkey wraps veggie wraps or
pizza for dinner
and sometimes ended the night with some
fruit or nachos or ice cream as a late
night snack
so dairy and cheese almost all day and
all night
the health coach asked yeah i guess so
amelia responded with the hesitant
uncertainty having never really thought
about it before
and how long would you say you've been
eating like this the health coach asked
um i suppose as long as i can remember
amelia answered
[Music]
a week or so later it would be
discovered that amelia had an extremely
high sensitivity
to casein a slow digesting protein
found in dairy products especially
cheese
this same protein also happened to be
known to cause and worsen
psychiatric conditions like
schizophrenia and depression
amelia was most likely born with a low
tolerance to casein
which also likely increased this effect
and she ate tons of it
her whole life amelia was instructed to
simply reduce her cheese consumption to
near zero
which she agreed to do it was just
cheese after all
[Music]
on march 15 2004 amelia was in her first
interview
after having not been interviewed for
nearly eight years
it was a public broadcasting service
interview about her career
why her work suddenly changed where she
went
and her anticipated comeback that was
being rumored
eventually after some skillful but
respectful coaxing by the interviewer
emilia explained what had happened she
told him about her dietary condition
and how when she changed her diet she
quickly began to feel the best she had
ever felt in her life
she suddenly felt like her brain had
been cleaned out of all the sludge and
rust inside the folds
she still thought about the same things
from the same relative vantage point
but her thoughts seemed to affect her
differently less
like the weight had been partly emptied
out of them and once they stopped
bearing down on her so much
they didn't compel her to fight back or
flail so much
and so i didn't really feel inspired to
write about you know dark or
serious things anymore i just felt like
writing about nicer
more lighthearted stuff but honestly
that got pretty boring pretty quick
and then i just didn't really feel like
writing much at all amelia explained
and after having received so many bad
reviews and degrading media coverage
regarding my newer work
and after my fans disliked how sharply
my stuff changed
i just stopped trying to force myself to
release anything new and so that's when
you quit the interviewer clarified
yeah sort of i mean i still wrote but
nothing serious
nothing to put out amelia responded
so what you're saying is sometimes the
secret to good art
is cheese the interviewer said in a
joking but still somewhat respectful
tone
amelia laughed but not because she
thought it was that funny
so i guess my next question would have
to be the interviewer went on with
are you eating cheese again what's worth
more to you
the success of your work or the more
pleasant state of mind
[Music]
you